Alright, when starting out with version control in a production pipeline, it can be a little
intimidating and, in order to help with understanding source control, we will begin with some
core concepts.
First up, what is source control?
While you might already be familiar with this concept, in a nutshell, source control
is a means of providing a backup or redundancy in project and file management on a production.
It is the management of changes to your computer files and assets over time.
It allows you to track versions or revisions of files and assets as they are changed and
most commonly it is referred to as revision control or version control.
Several version control solutions are integrated into Unreal Engine through the use of plugins
that should be active automatically such as Git SCM, Perforce, Subversion, and Plastic
CSM.
You can even use ShotGrid Toolkit for version control, but that will need you to enable
the plugin before it can be used.
Now source control can be formal or informal, and software is the means by which your
production formalizes that process.
While solutions can vary depending on your production needs, the best solutions we recommend
are using a system like Perforce, SVN, or Git.
Another solution that is good but not great is something that uses a central storage system
like Box or OneDrive.
ShotGrid Toolkit falls somewhere between the OK and Good categories, but is still
a viable solution.
If you're just using a network drive or naming out files that are stored on a dedicated
external hard drive, that's an OK solution but one that is risky for both your production
and data.
Finally, leaving everything up to chance, storing your files on your internal hard drive,
and just hoping for the best is universally considered a bad solution.
But you only live once, so if you are dead set on the YOLO solution, go for it.
What's the worst that could happen?
The answer is terrible things.
Terrible terrible things.
Please don't employ this as your version control solution.
Alright, now that you're familiar with what source control is, you probably want
to know why you should use a source control solution.
Well, source control allows you to have options that may save you in the future from
disaster.
A moment ago I mentioned redundancy and backup.
If something goes wrong, and inevitably it will, you can recover previous versions
of the work that you've done and save your production.
You can, through source control, merge changes, so if a team member updates an asset or
there is a small tweak, like the change of a color on a part of the asset, you can merge
those changes and then go back to previous versions if a director or producer changes
their mind after viewing the results.
Your teams can share and distribute work between different users, and even different studios,
with partition streams for access.
Source control helps your InfoSec team maintain data security in a centralized location.
It allows productions or projects to rapidly scale working environments so that multiple
users can be added or removed as needed.
And overall, it's going to give you a better performance solution.
So where does source control fit into the production workflow?
Well, source control is the foundation of your collaborative workflow, and there are
several options for version control solutions.
Systems such as Git SCM, Perforce, which is the most common, and ShotGrid can also
serve as a source control option.
Additionally, if you are working in UEFN, the Unreal Revision Control is a built-in
source control option available for UEFN art teams to collaborate more effectively.
With that said, this course will focus on Perforce as our version control solution
and the foundation of our collaborative production pipeline.
As we start out with Perforce as the version control solution, there are two other core
pillars of our collaborative workflow that will be explored and filled in a little bit later.
That's it for the core concept.
In our next section, I'll walk you through the basic workflow of a version control environment.